quand je suis arrivé ici j'étais
vraiment très timide et grâce à la salle
co2 deuxième chance je suis certes ils
sont beaucoup chaque année dans le même
cas kim anh des jeunes parfois perdus ou
en échec scolaire l'école de la deuxième
chance leur donne l'occasion de prendre
un nouveau départ et des rentrées ont
lieu tous les mois et le parcours au
sein de l'établissement se fait de
manière personnalisée ce qui permet de
trouver rapidement une solution pour
l'avenir de l'élève et veulent que le
bonheur des du gène ça veut dire trouver
un métier sortir avec avec une formation
avec un travail en tout cas sortir avec
un truc qui est positif à l'école de la
deuxième chance les jeunes alternent
entre deux semaines de cours et deux
semaines de stage dans le milieu
professionnel
il bénéficie d'une rémunération
mensuelle et de la gratuité dans les
transports franciliens au sein de
l'établissement les élèves sont épaulés
sur les savoirs fondamentaux français
maths ou encore bureautique et sont
accompagnés individuellement par un
formateur référent qui les soutient dans
toutes leurs démarches
une petit bonheur c'est de voir
justement que tout d'un coup ils sont
capables de trouver par eux mêmes
devoirs que tout d'un coup ils sont
capables de comprendre qu'effectivement
non ils sont pas plus nul que les autres
au contraire quoi c'est juste de
systèmes qu'ils peut-être les a écrasés
d'une façon ou d'une autre je n'en sais
rien mais en tout cas j'aime bien les
voir grandir et se rendre compte de ce
que de leur valeur l'établissement est
présent sur trois sites dans le
département attrape les mureaux et
magnanville chaque année plus de 400
jeunes passent par les rangs de l'école
de la deuxième chance des yvelines